more spidey suits for miles morales
revealed aoc's among us stream is one of
the biggest twitch streams
ever and could more ghosts of sushima be
coming i'm lucy let's jump into the news
insomniac has revealed more suits for
miles morales via
where else the daily bugle first up is
the crimson cow
suit it's mostly red and has a hood
second is miles famous tracksuit which
has spidey's traditional blue and red
plus black and white this suit is
actually a pre-order bonus for the game
but it's also unlockable by just playing
it
in 2018's marvel spider-man each costume
featured unique abilities that could be
used in combat
it's not clear yet what abilities might
be attributed to each of miles outfits
but it's presumably going to follow the
same formula abilities could also be
used with other costumes once unlocked
letting you look your best while
fighting your best at the same time
spider-man miles morales is a ps5 launch
game launching on november 12th
aoc played among us on twitch and it was
one of the biggest streams
ever congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
streamed the game with a bunch of
streamers including pokemane
hassan abby jacksepticeye dr lupo as
well as fellow u.s house representative
ilhan omar the three-hour stream pulled
in over 430
000 concurrent viewers on aoc's page
alone making it the third most popular
stream
ever on twitch the most popular stream
of all time is ninja and drake playing
fortnite back in 2018
which had 600 000 concurrents and in
second place is shroud's return to the
platform
aoc was streaming to encourage people to
go out and vote and if you haven't done
so yet
go and do it don't be sus sucker punch
may have just released ghosts of sushma
legends but it looks like it has plans
for the future
a new job listing for the studio asks
for a narrative writer with experience
in feudal japan
suggesting either more content for
ghosts of sushima or a potential sequel
a sequel wouldn't be surprising big sony
franchises like god of war and
spider-man are getting them
more content is also not out for
question especially with the game's
recent legends update which adds co-op
to the game and a raid is on the way
ghost of sushma will be playable via
backwards compatibility on the
playstation 5 and sucker punch confirmed
it'll run at 60 frames per second
on the brand new console and speaking of
new consoles for more on the playstation
5 and xbox series s and x
keep your eyes peeled for generation
next every friday here on youtube.com
gamespot and gamespot.com i'm on twitter
at lucy james games and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you